all right hello everyone
I think we might as well to get started
if more people are arriving then just
please come in but I think I might as
well start on time so that because I
have a lot of stuff to cover so thank
you all for coming
my name is Marc seaman if you want to
know more about me there's an about page
there on blah blah couplet idk I should
somehow see if I can get rid of that the
mouse pointer there excuse me
no let's see if that works
no you just have to live with that let's
see if I can put it down here somewhere
okay now you don't see it all right so
I've also on Twitter at play if you
think that's interesting I think Twitter
is quite useful actually so I'd love
feedback there so I'm going to talk
about functional architecture today and
specifically about these things called
pits of successes and then I'm going to
cover in just a moment and if you're
here and maybe you're a little bit
afraid that I'm going to talk about a
lot of complicated you know
sophisticated things well to some degree
I am but I'm also not going to assume
that you may have you know heard about
those things and I'm also not going to
assume that you already know how to read
and understand
f sharp code or Haskell code so even
though I'm going to show you a little
bit of code I'm not assuming that you
actually know how to read that so don't
worry about that I'll talk you through
the important points of that I'm also
going to show you a little bit of she
char code I assume that you understand
that so with that out of the way let's
just get started with there talking
about the pits of successes so imagine
that you have some sort of goals that
you need to reach in your software
development project and I'm not only
just talking about some sort of feature
that you need that you need to implement
but you may have a higher goal of saying
I want to enable my codebase to be
flexible and maintainable and all of
those things while I deliver features
and I want it to be long-term
maintainable so that I can also deliver
features requested by my business three
years from now and not you know go to my
stakeholders and ask for rewrite which
you know happens quite often so that's
the sort of things that I'm going to try
to talk about today's because that is
basically what software architecture is
about that those sauce
decisions also about scalability and all
sorts of other things it was so on but
one of those things that actually what
we call non-functional requirements so
you can imagine that you envision that
goal as having to be you know roll a
boulder on up the top up to the top of a
tall hill so if you've ever done any if
you've ever started you know physics you
know just classical and Newtonian
mechanics you'll know that if you have
to roll a boulder on top of a hill
you'll need to exert some force in order
to get it there so you'll need to expend
a lot of effort to actually roll the
boulder up the hill and if you are you
know able to actually roll it all the
way on top of the hill you can put it
there and if you're very very you know
precise in doing that you may actually
achieve an equilibrium and it stays
there but you probably also realized
that this equilibrium is extremely
unstable so if you don't place it
exactly in the right spot or if you have
some sort of disturbance to the system
it's going to start trying to roll down
one of the sides and you have to you
know you know exert more if I didn't
order to prevent it from doing that so
you you have to be constantly vigilant
and keep watch of what it is that's
going on in order to be able to achieve
your goal your goal is not something you
it's not something you only achieve but
you also something you need to keep on
watching you know whether it's it stays
there and and one of the problems with
that is you know this is what I often
feel it's like to be a software
architect or elite developer on a team
is you have to be constantly vigilant
because if if you just look away for a
moment you know if you are sick for a
couple of days or if you go on vacation
if you just go to too many meetings
what's going to happen is that you know
you just let it go for a moment and then
it you know everything rolls downhill
again and all the effort that you
expended on actually getting to your
that goal that is basically wasted
effort now and I you know I I feel like
a lot of software development feels like
that or at least that's what it used to
feel like for me so you know I spent
like at least a decade doing object
oriented design and and being all sorts
of you know playing all sorts of
different roles you know from an
individual contributor to either you
know a team lead to architect and such
things and you know I
did this a lot where I was constantly
you know looking out for things that
could cause the boulder to roll downhill
again in order to try to prevent that
from happening and I sort of just you
know you know I thought that that was
just what software development was all
about this was just you know an
intrinsic part of the of the of the game
if we if you will and then about five
six years ago I started to you know
learn about functional programming and I
got interested in this in fractional
programming for a lot of other reasons
and the more I started writing you know
code with functional programming the
more I realized that a lot of these
things that were very very difficult in
object-oriented design actually turns
out to be quite easy to do with
functional programming it almost happens
by itself so again if you can try to
reimagine your goal and saying well it's
not that you want to be on the top of a
hill that's not your goal it goes just
to reach an equilibrium you can say well
let's try to invert this and say you
just want to have an equilibrium so you
just roll your boulder down into the pit
and it just you know automatically rolls
down and stays there and even if you
have a disturbance to the system it's
just you know settles back into the
equilibrium again so this is what we
call a stable equilibrium and this is
really what functional programming feels
like for me these days and I just wanted
to share a little bit with you why I
think that is happening so I should
preface this right away by saying that
this talk is based on my experience with
writing F sharp code so if sharp is one
of those programming languages that have
a nice logo as you can tell which makes
it much more cooler than the other
language so so so a lot of this
least-experienced that I'm going to talk
about here today is based on my
experience with doing F sharp
programming and I've done lots of you
know just playing around fooling around
with F sharp but I also written real
production code that actually runs today
in F sharp as well so that is certainly
possible
I'm also basing some of this talk on my
experiences with the fooling around with
Haskell and Haskell is a programming
language that I don't have production
experience with but I've you know played
around with for quite a bit of time now
I need to say that these two languages
have a couple of things in common they
are both statically typed function
programming languages and the type
systems that they use are what we call a
hindley-milner type system and the
reason why I say that this is that there
are other programming languages other
functional programming languages out
there that do not belong to this family
of languages like a very popular one is
is Scala that's right that runs on the
JVM which is also statically typed as
far as I understand but it's not a Hindi
milliner type system and you also have
something like Clojure which is
dynamically typed and you have air lock
which is sort of I don't even understand
if it has a type system or not you know
every time I ask someone they say yes it
sort of has and said what does that mean
you know it sort of has types that's not
really helpful but anyways so you may
reach slightly different conclusions if
you're talking about those languages
instead of these languages but these are
the languages that that I'm going to
talk about right okay so so let's see
what we can do here with these with
these things here so I'm going to cover
three pits of success so the first one
I'm going to cover is something called
ports and adapters and I'll talk about
what that is when we get there I'm going
to talk about services entities and
value objects basically how do we think
about data and behavior and third I'm
going to talk about testability which is
really fun to talk about so it's not
that I only that I've only identified
three bits of success during my all the
these years of working with functional
programming I've actually identified you
know like eight or ten of them but I
don't have time to talk about all of
them so I just picked the ones that I
thought was the most important ones and
that is those three right so let's just
get the dive right into talking about
ports and adapters so port and adapters
is a well-known well described
software architecture and it's a very
will it's a very so it's a pretty good
architecture for doing enterprise as a
software so I've written lots of code
we're using the ports and adapters
architecture it has various names so one
of the names that it's known as is port
and adapters it's also known as
hexagonal architecture for reasons that
remain unclear to me because it doesn't
really look particularly you know
hexagonal this but and some people also
call it the onion architecture because
it you know has concentric layers just
like an onion in any sense
say this is basically what we know as
layered application architecture done
right so it's sort of like you know it's
a little bit of that also but it you
know it's related to that sort of
architecture and I'm not trying to tell
you that this architecture is bad I'm
just going to tell you that my
experience with this architecture it is
that in ood it's difficult to achieve
but actually the goal is great I really
like this architecture because it solves
a lot of problems basically what we are
trying to do with this architecture
we're saying in the middle there the
boxes in the middle represents your
domain model your business logic this is
the stuff that you actually care about
this is why you're building the software
because you have some sort of business
logic that is important to automate so
this is actually what or to you know
deliver value to your organization and
then you have you know layers that
protect that because you need that
business logic to you know interact with
all sorts of real world systems like you
need to draw graphical user interfaces
you need to write things into databases
you need to send emails and all of those
sorts of things but you don't want your
business logic to be too dependent on
all of those technical concerns because
they may change so you want to protect
you know the valuable parts of your
software from all the incidences all the
technical details so that's basically
what this sort of of application
architecture tries to achieve and that's
perfectly fine my experience with this
though is that this one it's like
rolling that Boulder of the hill is that
in the sense that it it's really
difficult just to explain to a team of
software developers never heard about
this before why you would want to do
this because it goes into a lot of
things about you knows the object the
design freedoms principles of
object-oriented design like the solid
principles for example and you need to
think about dependency injection and you
need to think about all these things
that you know in order to understand
those things you have to read thick
books about you know Robert C Martin who
is the original person or the person who
originally described the solid
principles he has a book called HR
principles patterns and practices and
this is seven hundred pages long book
that describe the solid principles and
gives you examples of how that is and
why it's interesting and so on you know
and I wrote a book about dependency
injection which i think is a good book
but it's 500 pages
and you know the book that these books
are so big should be a telltale sign for
us to say well if we need that many
pages to explain a concept maybe we
should start to think about if there's a
better way is that really the best we
can do so the first problem with this is
that it really takes a lot of effort
just rolling the boulder off the hill in
the sense that you need to make everyone
on a team understand why it's important
but then once you're there it's it's
even more difficult to stay there
because every small disturbance into the
system might actually destroy the entire
system for example you know if I'm Co if
I go on vacation or just sick for a
couple of days maybe what's going to
happen then is that there's some urgent
issue in your production system that you
need to address so you go in and say
well I'm you know in order to address
this urgent issue we'll just call the
database directly from the domain model
because you know we know that we can't
do that but we'll fix it later okay and
you know that later is never and and
that just causes this thing to you know
unravel very quickly again so it's not
really particularly you know stable so
so it's not that it's not impossible to
do with Java or C sharp but it's really
really difficult to do now what about
functional programming does functional
programming help and it does let's try
to understand why that is but basically
what I'm saying it's not that the
architecture is bad but basically that
just that it's difficult to achieve this
architecture with the at least with the
object-oriented languages that we
normally use whereas you know with
functional programming it sort of tends
to fall into this sort of architecture
all by itself so let's try to understand
why that is so let's let's start to talk
about what is the design ideal of
functional programming well in factional
programming we really like these things
called pure functions and why do we like
to pure functions we like pure functions
because they're easy to reason about
they're easy to manipulate and they they
are you know easy to compose and they
have all sorts of nice qualities about
them it also turns out they're easy to
test for reasons that I'll explain later
so so we really like our pure functions
that that is the design ideal of a
function in a function programming code
base so
what is a pure function we need to
understand that a pure function is a
function first of all that is
deterministic it always returns the same
output if you give it the same input the
other thing about a pure function is
that it has no side effects
a side effect may be that you know you
send an email it may be that you you
know write files or disk you delete a
record from a database it may also just
be that you change you know a value in
memory so it might not be something that
involves IO but anything that is
observable from outside of the function
if it changes the state of something
outside of the function we call that a
side-effect so it needs to do neither of
those it can't do they can't do
side-effects it can't do non determinism
if it's deterministic has no side effect
we call it a pure function so so you
probably go then but but side effects
you know all software development is is
basically all about you're doing side
effects you know when we create software
we want to you know print unique new UI
on the screen of the user that's a side
effect we want to send off emails that's
a side effect we want to put things into
a database that's a side effect why
would we ever you know be how would we
ever be able to do something if we can
only do a pure functions and we never
say that you can't that you can only do
pure functions we just say we like pure
functions so we want to maximize how
many pure functions we have but we
absolutely acknowledge that we also need
to have impure functions because we need
to write to databases we need to update
your user interface and we need to do
all of those things we just say we
prefer the pure functions because
they're easier to develop they're easier
to maintain so there's a couple of
relationship between those two things
that you that you need to understand
first of all if you have a pure function
and you want to call another pure
function from that pure function that is
absolutely okay you can do that you know
it doesn't make your calling pure
function more or less pure that it calls
another pure function that's just a way
of composing things makes absolutely
sense if you have an impure function and
you want to call another impure function
from that impure function you can
absolutely do that doesn't change
whether it's more or less impure that's
possible you can also call a pure
function from an impure function you
know if if the function is already
impure it doesn't become more
while is impure by calling pure
functions and you know pure function is
something as simple as two plus two so
you can definitely do you know two plus
two equals four even though you're in an
impure context you're trying to save
something into the database that's
absolutely possible you know going the
other way on the other hand is not
possible and there various ways it's not
possible in Haskell for example it
wouldn't even compile I'll show you what
that looks like in a moment in F sharp
it's not that you can't sort of do it if
you imagine that you have a function
that's pure at the moment but then you
want to change the implementation a
little bit and the change you introduce
is a call to an impure function what's
actually going to happen then is it will
compile but that you know your function
that was you know pure before now also
becomes impure because it's calling into
another impure function so it just you
know moves from one place to the other
one you could you could say so you can't
go the other way you can't call impure
code from pure code that that's really
important let's try to see an example
what that would look like and why that
is important because this is basically
the explained explanation for why we
tend to fall into this ports and
adapters architecture when we do
functional programming right okay so
let's look at an example so one of my
favorite examples is you know a scenario
where you try to implement a system for
doing with you know restaurant
reservation so you know this these exist
already but this is just too you know
it's a nice rich you know problem domain
so it's nice to talk about so you
imagine that you want to make a
reservation on the restaurant you go to
you know website on app fill in some
details and then you hit a button to
send off your reservation and in this
particular scenario what we can imagine
then is that there's a JSON document
that your you know user interface
somehow posts to an HTTP based server
and the HTTP based server receives that
JSON documents and wants to deal with it
so we will go through five steps here
the first thing we need to do is is to
validate the incoming JSON because Jason
is not particularly strongly typed so
we'll need to validate is it actually
well-formed do we understand what is
being said here if it's valid we can
move on if it's invalid we'll need to
you know return the response we'll get
back to that later on but imagine that
we've determined that this is a valid
you know will form JSON document it
means we understand what it's trying to
say
means we understand the the date on
which the reservation is being attempted
that that means also we'll need to look
into our database to say how many or you
know how many existing reservations do
we already have for that date
how many reserved seats do we have from
that date that date yeah from that date
let's read that from the database now we
have enough information to make a
business decision you know do we
actually have enough excess capacity to
accept the reservation if we have we can
save the reservation into the database
so that it becomes part of the decision
when the next you know request comes in
we might be short-circuiting various
ways in various steps here because if we
can't validate we no reason to go
through the rest if we decide that we
can't accept the reservation there's no
reason to save it into the database so
we might short-circuit at various points
but I'm not showing those arrows but
what we might want to do anyway do you
know independent of the decision we
reach we want to say well let's
translate our decision back into an HTTP
response that can then be sent back to
the client so those are the five steps
that we need to go through and you will
notice that three of them are green and
three of them are not red but purple and
the three obviously are the pure
functions and the the purple ones are
the impure functions but you also
noticed that they're sort of into lead
so we have those three pure functions
and we have those two impure functions
and we somehow need to you know make
them in you know mix them together and
we'll wonder how we can do that so let's
try to look like a look at what that
would look like so I'm going to show you
some Haskell code and I'm not assuming
that you know Haskell at all what's
really important here is just the top
line so actually everything but the top
line is the only reason why so the top
line is the function declaration and
it's type and the rest of it is actually
the implementation of the function all
the whites and and so on beneath that
and you don't really I you don't really
need to read that just read the top line
here I just put the other limb function
body there to you know show off that I
can actually write Haskell code haha but
it's not important let's look at the top
line there the validate reservation the
blue and the orange stuff here so
validate reservation just declares
here's a function it's name is validate
reservation the orange stuff then is the
type of the function it says it takes
something called reservation rendition
as input this is sort of our you know
Haskell representation of the JSON
document it returns something called
either arrow reservation its output it's
not particularly important exactly what
that means what's important here to
realize is that this function is pure
and it's guaranteed by the compiler to
be pure why how do we know that well
basically because in Haskell all
functions are pure by default so unless
explicitly stated otherwise they are
pure and this one does not explicitly
state that it's impure and therefore
it's pure and because the type is is
declared as being pure if I try to do
something in the function body there
that was impure it wouldn't compile but
I'm not trying to do something impure in
the function body there so this compiles
and it's fine now what does it look like
if if we want to explicitly state that a
function is impure well it looks like
this so I'm just going to show you a
function declaration without it's it's
its implementation so this is the next
function next function in that little
sequence diagram that I showed you get
reserved seats from DP so it takes a
connection string and its own time
that's basically just a representation
of the date and then it returns
something called IO of int and this is
impure and the reason why we know that
is because those two letters IO
indicates that this is an impure
function so basically what it's
returning IO of interest is an integer
so it returns the number of already
reserved seats for that sone time but
that integer you know originates from an
impure context because it's not
deterministic you know reading from a
database is not deterministic you could
read from a database you know calling
the same database query twice and you'll
get two different results because the
state of the database changed in the
meantime so that's not deterministic so
so that is an impure operation but
basically what I owe of into says is
that there is an integer but it's it's
packaged up inside of an impure context
so you can almost think about this
impure context as being sort of like a
little bubble or a little space that is
sort of you know sits around that
integer and when you're outside when you
are in the pure context you can see the
the bubble or box or whatever you want
to call it where that integer is inside
but you can't see what the integer is so
it's a little bit like Schrodinger's cat
maybe I don't know
not really but anyway so you know that
you have something that contains an
integer but as long as you're in a pure
context you don't know what that integer
is so how do we get that integer I'll
get back to that but you know I talked
about how you can't call an impure
function from a pure function but I'd
like my business logic to be impure
because basically I just like as much as
possible of my you know code to be pure
so what I want to be able to make a
decision so I could write a new function
called check capacity and I could just
if I just for a moment forget about this
you know distinction between between
pure and impure I could say well in my
ideal dream world I'd like to have an
integer which represents the number of
already reserved seeds and I also need
you know an integer that represents the
capacity of the city of the restaurant
so you know that might be just another
number like the restaurant could hold
ten people or I can hold a hundred
people or whatever so I need those
numbers and then then I also need the
reservation itself if I have those three
pieces of information I can make a
decision that is a pure function how do
we know that because there's no IO
involved in the type declaration there
so I'm sort of just you know brushing
aside that I don't actually have an int
for the reserved C's I have an IO of int
so how do I get it out well I'll get
back to that but it turns out to be
possible but you know if if I did that
though I decide maybe if I decide to
accept the reservation I could say well
all right
let's save the the reservation into the
database again now that is another
impure operation we can see that because
it's it returns IO of nothing but those
empty brackets there we call those unit
and both F sharp and Haskell has this
thing called unit and it's basically
void like it ought to be because unit is
a real value so you can use you know
unit as a return value but you also use
it as input so you can take a return
value and you know pass it on its input
to another function if you need to do
that and that turns out to sometimes be
and be interesting to do but but if you
think about those empty brackets as
being sort of the same thing as void in
c-sharp or Java you know that if you
have a method in Java Java that returns
void
it's it it pretty strongly indicates
that there must be a side effect of
calling that method because why would
you call a method that doesn't return
anything you probably want to want to
want to achieve some sort of side effect
so that's a that's possible also in
Haskell but it's only possible to have
side effects in an impure context
because side effects are per definition
impure so we have you know IO of unit
now the final thing we need to do is to
say well if we reach the decision so far
we want to translate it back to an HTTP
result so we could do that as well
again you just look at the top line
there we can see there's no IO involved
in that so that's a pure function as
well this is just a translation from our
internal representation of you know did
we accept the reservation or not and
then just something that can that we can
you know translate to you know HTTP
responses that can go on the wire that's
basically what we're doing here alright
so so we have those five functions I
wrote three pure functions two impure
functions I somehow need to again you
know interleave those so that they can
all talk together because I need some of
the impure information in order to
continue with some of the pure the pure
operations but I said I can't Corp your
functions no that's I can't call impure
functions from pure functions so how do
I resolve that issue well it turns out
that you know at the boundary of the
system every system is impure because
you know when you get a request coming
in to a system or someone presses a
button on a user interface or whatever
that is non-deterministic side-effect
behavior anyway so everything that
happens you know at the entry point of a
system is by definition impure anyway so
so we could imagine that we have some
sort of entry point where you could say
well if we if you put all those
functions into some sort of web
framework we could imagine that we have
some sort of framework that that you
know contains a dispatcher and it says
well alright here here's a JSON document
that arrives at this particular URL it
ought to be dispatched to a function
that can deal with that and that is an
impure function so we need to have an
impure function that could deal with an
incoming request anyway so let's use
that in that function to compose all of
those other things together so in this
case I've just called it post
reservation and if you look at the top
line again the orange stuff you can see
it takes reservation rendition as input
returns IO of
to be result of unit as output so very
clearly this is impure as well this has
side effects or non-deterministic
behavior inside of it and that means we
can do everything when we're in impure
context we can call pure functions and
impure functions so we're pretty much
all almost there and we can just walk a
you know through a couple of the details
so don't worry about all the haskell ii
scary stuff like all the strange looking
arrows and dollar signs and so on that's
basically you can think about that as
glue that enables you to compose
functions together and i'm not going to
walk you through all of it but basically
just if you look at the you can see
there for indented lines if you look at
the top indented line that one that
starts with our arrow whose host either
and so on you can see after the dollar
sign it says validate reservation
candidate that's a function call the
validate reservation was the first
function that i showed you and that's a
pure function and it returns a value and
we do gloomy stuff to that value in
order to you know be able to address it
later on and then if you look at the
next line you can see there's more
haskell googly [ __ ] there but after the
dollar sign it says get reserved seats
from DP and a couple of you know input
arguments to that and so again you know
i'm in a pure context i'm inside of the
impure bubble if you will so that means
i can call both pure and impure
functions or everything goes here and
that means now that i that sits on the
left-hand side of that arrow that is the
result of calling get reserved seats
from DP and you saw before when i
declared the function i said it which
says io of int but i'm now you know open
the door and went inside of the io
context and that means the AI is now no
longer an eye of it it's just an INT
isn't because i'm already in the impure
context and that mean i can pass that as
an argument to check capacity so that's
the next the next last line there it
says hoist either you know Haskell goo
boo goo host either dollar and then says
check capacity 10 I R so 10 is just
because I hard-coded the capacity of the
restaurant very small intimate
restaurant you can only see 10 people
but then I is just the number of already
reserved seats that's just an integer at
this point so even if check capacity is
a pure function I'm calling
from an impure context so that all works
and then there's some more crap going on
there now if we try to visualize what's
going on here we can try to draw it in
with concentric circles funny how that
works out and so basically what happened
here is to say well we get the incoming
request it's being dispatched to this
function called post reservation which
is an impure function that's the one
that I just showed you on a previous
slide now the first thing post
reservation does is it says let's try to
validate the incoming data if we can do
that let's try to call the database to
get the number of already with seats
reserved seats from the database with
that information we can now call check
capacity which is another pure function
if we decide to accept the reservation
we can come save reservation and then we
can you know no matter what we decided
we can return you know translate things
back into an HTTP result and you will
notice that I've drawn in the concentric
circles and you'll notice that I've made
some of the things purple and I'll make
some of some of the things green by
purpose because the green stuff is the
pure stuff and the purple stuff is the
impure stuff and it has to be like this
in Haskell because it's the only thing
that compiles because I have this
constraint that I can't call you know
impure code from pure code and I have to
structure my DJ in my application this
way so you will often hear Haskell a--'s
talk about you know IO happens at the
boundary of the system yes because
Haskell you know forces you to do it in
this way there's no other way you can
actually do it but if you sort of look
at this a little bit you will see that
that is very very close to being ports
and adapters this is basically the
portion adapters architecture in the
middle there check capacity that is my
business logic in the concentric circle
about that validate reservation to h-2b
result this is what you'd call your
application model or your service layer
whatever people tend to call it this is
where you adapt your business model to
the outside world and then you have the
the impure stuff on the boundary M and
you could even imagine if you just slice
it through horizontally you know through
the middle you basically have you know
your normal horizontally layered
application architecture because you
have your you know you are into
to the to the outside world on top and
then you have your application layer
then you have your domain month then you
have you data access layer there and the
bottle in the bottoms you can also you
can almost imagine that there's sort of
a can you know shape you know sitting
down here that represents your database
and then you have you know your
horizontally layer the application model
there but the thing is it just
automatically falls into this model
because that's basically all it can do
in Haskell specifically so if I was a
team leader on a Haskell project and and
you know I went on vacation and then you
had the same sort of urgency as before
where you say I really really want to
call the database you know from within
my domain model from within check
capacity because I really need to solve
the problem fast you could try to do
that but basically that would mean you
can only do that if you change the type
of the function to become impure and
changing the type of a function is a
breaking change and that means now all
the rest of your code is not going to
compile and and at that point it might
actually be easier to actually do the
right thing instead of trying to fix all
those breaking changes so you know it
really just helps you to do the right
thing up front and you can do the same
thing in F sharp as well.if sharp is not
so strict about its distinction between
pure and impure but this is the
basically the same composition as as I
showed you in Haskell before it doesn't
really enforce it but there are ways
that you can do do that if you're a team
lead or Software Architect on an f-sharp
project and it's not particularly it's
not particularly difficult to keep track
of whether you're doing the right thing
it shops sort of tends to fall into this
this thing this way of writing things
fairly easy as well I have a blog post
that shows all of this code if you're
interested in that so so you don't
really have to take a lot of notes if
you really want to dive into it and I
have that on my blog on my blog and if
you can't find it then ping me on
Twitter right so that's really nice that
we sort of just fall into this pit of
doing the right thing having the right
software architecture all by itself so
let's move on to talk about services and
data now when people you know initially
learn about object-oriented programming
and object-oriented design they they are
often taught that up Jake
our data with behavior and there's this
concept called encapsulation that says
you should not really expose the
internals of your objects what you
really should do is you should have your
objects expose enough operations so that
a user of the object can just ask it to
do things you know tell don't ask if you
will so so so that's this whole idea
about this whole design idea about
encapsulation and object orientation and
if people are you know neutral to
enterprise development and they're just
out of college or wherever they you know
learned object-oriented design they've
probably come out and they'll do designs
like this so they say I need to keep
track of a user in my system I have lots
of uses in my system and the users have
ID they have an IDE and they have a user
name I also need to persist my user in a
database so I'll do you know create read
update and delete that can talk to my
database and you know this is a well
described design pattern it's called
active record and you know if you read
Martin Fowler's book you know patterns
of enterprise application architecture
it's actually described in that book so
it sort of like almost seems like this
is some sort of of well-known good thing
but it's turned out that you know in the
last decade at least we've pretty much
experienced and learned the hard way
that this is probably more of an
anti-pattern that it's a pattern at
least this is sharpen and and in Java it
seems like it still does some good
things in Ruby I don't know but Ruby is
static is dynamically typed so maybe
other rules you know are at play there
so I'm not pointing fingers at Ruby at
all but I'm just saying well I'm talking
about statically typed languages here at
least in c-sharp and Java we've learned
the hard way that that is actually not a
good way to design systems even though
this seems very object-oriented you know
a user is an encapsulation of data about
the user together with all the behavior
that belongs to the user this seems like
object orientation this you know by
principle there's nothing wrong with
this but the problem is that you say
well I need to do things with users and
later on you figure out I need to do
other things with users as well you know
because I want to be able to send an
email to an user so I'll also add that
you know feature to the user object and
what often happens with these things is
that the more behavior you
to function to a class like this the
more behavior it also attracts so you
know you'd end up with a couple of very
very big classes in a typical source so
source code base that you know where the
class is just you know attract more and
more of this sort of behavior and they
become less and less cohesive and we end
up calling those big classes got classes
and that is a well-known anti pattern as
well so we learn the hard way that this
actually leads to some when something
that is not particularly maintainable so
what should we do about it well there is
say there's this book called domain
driven design by Eric Evans and it's
sort of like two books and one one of
the book one part of the book talks a
lot about this thing about actually
talking thinking about the domain and
the business language that you're trying
to model and so on but there's also a
part of the book that is very concrete
and talks about various design patterns
and how to think about objects and Eric
Evans makes a pretty good distinction
very interesting distinction in this
book that I think is very variable that
I have served me very well doing
object-oriented design in the last ten
years at least more and he says
basically you can think about your
objects as falling into two categories
and one of the categories has two
subcategories so basically he says well
the first category of objects we call
those entities and these are the these
are the objects that you learn about in
university and so on so if you if you
ever had you know an introduction to
object oriented analysis and design you
know the question is but how do I do
object oriented analysis and design and
the you know the naive answer to that
question is well just take the you know
the problem specification and just look
for all the nouns and the nouns will
describe your objects and we know that
that's not really true but there's some
truth in that is some of the nouns would
actually be some of the entities you are
interested in entities are objects that
have you know inherent identity that
have you know long lasting identity so
these are the the business objects you
want to keep track of these are your
users your contracts your orders if
you're keeping track of a fleet of cars
that is your know your car objects or
whatever it is that you're
even track of these are entities and you
probably have those and that's nothing
wrong with that
and then he also talks about well
there's another sort of object that also
contains data we call those value
objects and that's another well-known
design pattern but basically what what
Eric Evans then says is that these
objects are basically just carriers of
data and they don't really in they don't
really encapsulate any business logic
because we've learned that if we try to
put business logic inside of these
things business logic changes so it's
not a good idea to put business logic
that changes you know at a different you
know cadence that the data changes it's
not a good idea to you know put those
together so instead you should put your
business logic into collections other
objects that are collections of behavior
and it calls those things services and
you probably you know heard lots about
you know services this is basically just
another word for manager you know so you
have like your user manager and things
and all of a sudden you also have your
manager factory services and so on but
that's basically the stuff that he's
talking about here so what to see you
saw that we looked at before what does
it look like if we factor it to do what
Eric Evans tells us to do well it looks
something like this and we'll say all
right here's a user it has an ID and a
username and I even went to the effort
of making this immutable which I hadn't
needed to do but I just you know wanted
to do that and that's it it's just the
data and then we can say well what if we
need to you know make create read update
and delete operations on that oh well
for that we have the repository pattern
so you can have like your sequel use of
repository class that implements I use
of repository that does all of that now
that's another world well described
design pattern that everyone by the way
it gets wrong but that's a different
story
and if we want to send emails we can
have another you know service that does
that email sender so my experience with
doing this is that that actually works
you know if you if you need to do
object-oriented design and development
of a maintainable non-trivial system
this actually works this is a way to
keep a code base maintainable for years
but the problem
is you know you have to read thick books
in order to understand why you have to
do this and how to do it and you need to
give everyone on the same page so again
we're bit of that situation where it
feels like rolling Boulder of the hill
and again if you look away for just a
moment then someone comes by and totally
ruins everything and then you're back to
start again and not even that but also
you'd say but that's not really object
orientation anymore this is certainly
the anaemic mark that's an anemic domain
model right this that's a very common
criticism of this sort of code it says
well that's actually not object-oriented
code anymore because you've separated
you separated data from behavior that's
not what object orientation was
originally about oh maybe you know
everyone tries to second-guess what
Ellen came and when he coined the term
but I don't know but basically what we
taught about em you know C sharp and
Java that's not the sort of object
orientation we were originally thought
taught so what about functional
programming does it make it better you
betcha
because you know functional programming
basically wants you to do this it says
there that's data and there are
functions that operate on data and
that's it that's that is how you are
supposed to work with with with your
stuff this is how you're supposed to
write code in functional programming so
if we look at this same example again we
can say what is the user look like this
is an F sharp example of the user it's
just a one-liner it's almost declarative
well ladies declare it so if you say a
user is a type that has an integer ID
and as a string username and that's it
this is a strongly type type declaration
but it has no behavior and well in F
sharp you can at behavior because if
sharp is what we call a multi
paradigmatic language so you can make it
more object-oriented if you want to but
you shouldn't really feel the urge to do
this this is fine this is what it wants
you to do in Haskell for example there's
a little bit of a different syntax of
doing this but but it's basically the
same concept and in Haskell in Haskell
you can't add any behavior to data data
is data it could be as deeply nested and
very you know it has it has
a complex structure if you will but it's
just data it has no internal Associated
behavior so we should feel good about
this this is not anemic or anything this
is how functional programming should
look like and if we want to do things
with the user if we want to save it into
a database or something we can create a
module which is a collection of
functions that either you know take user
as an input or return user as output or
maybe even do both I don't know
these are impure by the way but that's
not really the point but the point is a
module is basically just a service but
it doesn't have to pretend that it's an
object because it's just a module and
you could have a module for sending
email as well so that's that's basically
just what what if sharp wants to want
you to do and this is what Haskell wants
you to do so it wants you to do what
Eric Evans spends 400 pages trying to
teach you how to do is basically if you
ever had learned Haskell or if you ever
learned if sharp you know the functional
parts of f-sharp this is what you are
supposed to do this is what the language
wants you to do so you're falling into
this pit of success again that's saying
well these two things should not go
together they should be separate but
they can you know work with each other
and that's fine much more maintainable
code base you get out of this alright so
let's talk about testability because
testability is always fun to talk about
you know Kent Beck introduced the
concept of test-driven development back
in mid-90s so 95 96 something like that
I can't remember the exact date and it
was really really controversial when he
started doing that and I picked a
test-driven development up in around
2003 it was really really controversial
back then there's you know there's been
more acceptance of test-driven
development now into the you know to the
degree where most people actually seem
to think that it ought to be you know
that's actually you know a well-known
best practice now but it turns out
there's still sort of controversial and
you know from time to time the
controversy you know pops up again so a
couple of years ago you know David
Hyneman Hansen wrote an article called
TDD is dead long live testing and
basically buddy I'll try to cover what
he said in the moment but basically said
well it's not that he's against testing
but he just thinks that test-driven
development actually leads to a lot of
problems
- what what he calls test induced damage
now david hire my hanson can be quite
controversial himself and some people
really don't like his style because he's
you know swearing a lot and he's saying
things in a very provocative manner but
you know i found over the years that if
you actually try to listen to what it is
that he's trying to say to you he's
really a free-thinking spirit he just
not just go with the flow he goes
against the grain and sometimes it seems
like he makes an you know and you know
an effort out of doing that but
basically if you say something that goes
against the grain it's worth the effort
at least to try to understand what it is
he says because he's a very intelligent
young man
I can I can say young man now because my
hair is gray so let's try to understand
what it is that he says he says
test-driven development leads to tests
induced damage that is his claim I'm not
saying it's my claim is that is his
claim let's try to understand what he
means by test induced damage so here is
a class and the cold capacity checker
that tries to check the capacity of one
of these restaurant reservation system
so this is nice testable she sharp code
we have a class called capacity check
out it implements an interface called
high capacity checker it it uses
dependency injection to have a capacity
that's just an integer but also an IEEE
reservation repository and will need to
have the constructor in order to depend
to inject those in and save them in
fields for later usage then we have on
the bottom here has capacity which is
the actual value that this class
provides it says well given a
reservation do we have capacity yes or
no true or false so what we do here and
the last two lines of code there we say
well we'll ask the repository to get the
number of reserved seats for that date
that gives us a number of reserve seats
reserved it's just an integer and then
we say then we just do a comparison you
know a less than comparison and says
well if the capacity capacity is less
than that you know what we already have
reserved plus what is being requested
then the answer is is false otherwise
it's true so so david Heine Maya
Hansen's point here would be why would
you ever write code like that you know
the only valuable thing here is those
two lines of code in the bottom the rest
is just
noise why would you do that and then you
say well because of testability alright
fair enough so I'm not even saying that
this is bad in the sense that you know
if you ask me to write a non-trivial
maintainable system in c-sharp that has
you know test coverage this is what I do
because I I don't know of a better way
of doing it in c-sharp so I'm not really
pointing fingers at you know this is I'm
not saying this is bad practice you may
need to do this but that is that is a
high cost to pay to have you know
testability because that really it
causes your code to be spread out
instead of being you know going well
together and it's difficult to manage
and difficult to your navigated code
base like that and you just have another
lot of noise that you don't really need
to have what would it look like in
another language like an f-sharp for
example now here's something it's not
even similar because this actually does
much more it makes the same sort of
boolean comparison but then it also
instead of just returning true or false
it actually returns a failure with some
more information about the failure if
you know why it failed if that's what's
the case or in return success you know
if if the boolean external so if I just
wanted to do it entirely similar to the
other one just returning a boolean I
could actually have done that in two
lines of code but now it turns out to be
full now this isn't you know apart from
that this is exactly the same thing
because this this is a function called
check and it takes three arguments it
takes a capacity argument that's just an
integer it takes get reserved seeds
which turns out to be another function
and then it takes reservation as the
third argument so what you often see in
functional programming is that you will
see functions taking other functions as
argument this is what we call
higher-order functions this is a
completely normal thing to do now get
reserved seats is a function it plays
the exact same role as that repository
that you saw before so on the first line
you can see it says let reserved seats
equal get reserved seats reservation dot
date that is that is a function call
I'm calling the function get reserved
seeds with the reservation state and I
get in I'm getting out of that function
called the number of already reserved
seeds that function
is just being passed in and it's sort of
polymorphic because I'm not asking for a
specific function I'm just asking for a
function that can take a date as input
and give me an integer as output any
function like a does you can do that
fits that description and that will
compile now is this function that we're
looking at here is that pure or impure
it turns out to be important in just a
moment so therefore the question is this
pure impure well it turns out that most
of the stuff that goes on up here is
actually pure the only thing we don't
really know about is we don't know what
get reserved seeds actually does so it
may be pure it may be impure now if get
reserved seeds is sort of like the
repository like it's actually querying a
database to get the number of already
reserved seeds that's an impure
operation because it's not deterministic
it depends on the state of the database
so in that case it would be impure and
if it's if it's impure if that is a
database called then all of this
function also becomes impure that's how
we know how that's how it works in the
char on the other hand if get reserved
seeds is a pure function then this
function is also pure because there's
nothing else in that implementation that
could make it impure why is that
interesting it's interesting because it
turns out that pure functions are always
testable and I'll get back to why that
is but let's just look at what would
your tests look like what would a unit
test look like of this function here's
just one example I'm only going to show
you one example just to give you an idea
about it so the scenario here is that I
want to test that it returns the correct
results if there are no prior
reservations in the system so the system
just booted up there are absolutely no
reservations the restaurant just opened
and I want to check the first
reservation that comes into the system
that's basically the scenario here so
I'm saying well I need to set up a
little bit of context I need to define
what the context is so I say well what's
the capacity of the restaurant I've just
you know hard coding that in this test
case 210 because well that suggests an
easy number to think about I like the
number 10 and the number 1 and so on so
that's just arbitrary but it's just to
have a test case then I say for the in
on the next line I say let get reserved
seats underscore equals 0 the underscore
means that I don't care about the input
this is a local function this is a
function that only belongs to this test
case but
it always returns zero no matter what
the input is that is a pure function
because it is as deterministic as
possible it always returns zero that
means there are never any real sort of
seats in this particular scenario that's
a pure function and then I have this let
get read reservation and then a lot of
crap you know with with a lot of stuff
yes by the way this is my email address
you know all the spammers already have
it so you might as well get it as well
so so that's just you know that's a
little bit that looks a little noisy
because there's actually a lot of code
there but it's but it's just data and we
could put that in some sort of factory
if we wanted to do that but I just I'm
just showing you a self-contained
example here and then you know on the on
the third to last line there it says lit
actual equal capacity check capacity get
reserved seats reservation I'm taking
those three arguments that I set up in a
range face and just passing them as
arguments I'm getting an actual result
back I can and I can now you know
declare what did I expect and compare
those two things to each other and this
test will either pass or fail that was
easy
so you might wonder now is it
coincidental that this was easy to test
and it turns out it's not there is a
reason why this was easy to write and
the reason is that as long as a function
is pure it is intrinsically testable and
let's try to understand why that is in
order to get help to understand that
let's refer to Jessica care and just
care sometimes talks about a concept
that she calls isolation and she says
isolation is you know when the only
information a function has about the
external world is something that is
passed into it via arguments then the
function has isolation and that is a
good thing by the way this is so you
know a desirable quality of a function
and so it's basically what we're saying
is a function does not have any implicit
knowledge about the outside world
everything it needs to know in order to
do what it is that it wants to do needs
to be passed in as arguments now is a
pure function isolated yes always
because a pure function you know it must
be deterministic
otherwise it's not pure and by
deterministic we're saying it should
always return the same output given the
same input it is only the input that can
influence the output of a function so
therefore a pure function is the subset
of all functions that have isolation
they you know the f-sharp function that
I just showed you may not be pure we
talked about that but it has isolation
because it makes no attempt of you know
using it you know implicit knowledge
about the world everything it tries to
do is based on its function argument so
it has isolation it may not be pure
maybe it is we don't know but at least
pure functions the ideal of functional
programming or pure functions have
isolation why is isolation interesting
let's talk about unit testing my sense
of isolation you know important in the
context of unit testing well you know
let's try to see if we can come up with
a definition of unit testing basically
you know if you have ten experts in unit
testing and you ask them to come up with
a definition of what a unit test is
you'll get 12 answers so so it's not
really possible to get you know one
definition of a unit test but here's one
that I use a unit test is an automated
test that tests a unit in isolation from
its dependencies and most experts and
unit testing where they disagree is
where all the controversy is is it means
it's basically around you know what is a
unit and I'm not particularly interested
in when a unit is the thing that I'm
interested in in this definition is the
word isolation we want to test the unit
in isolation of its dependencies this is
the same sort of isolation that jessyca
car talks about all right so let's try
to understand why you know my David
Heine my handsome maybe up onto
something and why it's not a concern in
functional programming
so David Hina Maya Hansen says well
isolation is an important quality of
your code if you want it to be testable
and then you know you try to combine
that with object-oriented programming
and bang you have test induced damage
and why I think that David Hina Maya
Hansen draws the wrong conclusion he
says and that's the fault of test-driven
development whereas I'm more and more
beginning to see I can do test-driven
development with it with functional
programming and it it just it doesn't it
does not
to leave to lead to tests induce damage
so therefore the problem must be
somewhere else and I think actually Opie
is the problem so let's try to
understand why I object-oriented
programming is it's a problem here
now the idea the design idea the
philosophy behind over P is
encapsulation this is what we are aiming
for this is what we were taught is
important in object-oriented design if
we want to be testable we now need to
aim for this quality of isolation
because otherwise it's not really
testable now again we are we're in this
situation where we're trying to roll a
boulder up the hill it is possible to
sit there in the intersection between
those two you know sets and say here is
testable oh-oh-oh D it is possible but
again you know it requires a lot of
effort and it requires a lot of
diligence and a lot of you know constant
monitoring of what's going on because
otherwise you'll probably add to one of
the sides and what's often happening is
if you don't if you don't have a focus
on you know test-driven development or
testability you may add to the side of
the encapsulation that's basically that
what happened the first ten years of the
dotnet framework for example you know
the first ten years of the base class
library internet it was infamous for not
being particularly testable it's been
it's much better now but but it was
really difficult to test you know base
class libraries the first ten years of
you know mid-life the.net framework
lifetime now on the other hand if you
are focusing on test-driven development
you often err to the side of isolation
and and then you get something that is
you know that has this test induced
damage that that David Heine my hands
and talks about but in functional
programming is different because what's
the ideal function in functional
programming well it's that pure function
that we already talked about that is the
design ideal it has isolation and
because it has isolation its testable
there may be other ways to make things
testable but if they have isolation they
tend to be testable but there is no you
know there's no intersection that you
need to fit into basically you know if I
had a team of you know developers who
are already good at doing functional
programming
I could basically just you know say to
them if I was the lead developer or
software architect I could say just
write as many pure functions as you can
do good functional programming design
write pure functions and I'll go on
holiday and I'll come back and then
we'll see then we can start testing it
that might actually be possible because
you know if they write pure functions
they are testable so what I've tried to
do here in in this talk is to talk about
you know in my experience there are
there were lots of things more than
three things that I've experienced
during my career as architect and lead
developer and so on where I say this
requires a lot of effort this is really
difficult to do in c-sharp and probably
also in java but it turns out that you
know if i try to rephrase the way that I
approach my things and use you know
functional programming instead all of
these things just sort of automatically
you know fall into a successful place it
just automatically happens so we looked
at three things we looked at ports and
adapters we looked at services entities
and value objects we looked at
testability all of these things turn out
to to work very well it's not the only
three I know of others but I didn't have
time for you know to describe anymore if
you want to know more then well you can
come and talk to me afterwards I will
not have time to do Q&A right now but
I'm happy to talk to you afterwards
otherwise you can also visit my blog I
you know block a lot about these things
I also have blue psychosis I have blown
psychosis on you know test-driven
development unit testing functional
programming all sorts of things and you
know since I go under the pseudonym blur
I just created this bit lead slash blur
plural sight so that's just a link to
all my courses if you don't have a flow
side subscription you can come and get a
voucher I have I'll get it out in the
moment I have vouchers that'll give you
a one month a trial subscription to pull
aside for free so you can come and get
those if you need them but otherwise
I'll let you go for lunch in ten seconds
I just want to say if you if you if you
have questions then come and talk to me
now or in the hallway or if you see me
around in the conference or send me an
email or whatever I'll be happy to
answer any questions that you have but
some of you want to go to lunch now and
I think you should do that so thank you
all for coming and have a nice lunch